alright the big news of the week Taylor
Swift's twitter was hacked you gotta
have to step authentification lady don't
you know that they got the blue check
you can get that yeah so somebody hacked
into Twitter Taylor Swift's Twitter
account and you know they were posted a
bunch of [ __ ] okay fine a few tweets got
go viral big deal but what I thought was
interesting about this was that suddenly
Entertainment Weekly all the news
magazines started printing out her DMS
so she had a bunch of DMS with famous
people and other musicians and people
just started printing them out and
posting them online and all over the
place and you know we've had so much of
this stuff go on with hacking of course
with the Sony hack and the interview and
all that and then we had all the naked
pictures of the the female celebrities
that have gone out there and I have a
huge problem with this because these
people that are posting this stuff and
all these writers for these magazines
better posting the stuff they wouldn't
want their personal [ __ ] being put out
there right they don't want their
personal emails think about you watching
this right now having nothing to do with
the industry you don't want your
personal emails to be able to be used
against you or your personal dm's or
your facebook messages or your snapchats
or the rest of it now we all know but
none of this stuff is truly private and
yet we still all put it out there and we
still but there are times when you write
things that are meant for that one
person that's it that could be construed
in every which way and even though there
was nothing bad necessarily in Taylor
Swift's dm's actually most of the
articles were saying how she actually is
the person that you see that sort of
plastic sort of you know there's not
much tour kind of person that you see
publicly that that's exactly who she is
privately so it's not even about the
information versus in the Sony hack
where they're the executives were saying
like kind of race this stuff and kind of
sex and stuff and talking about how you
know women were making less than men and
all that kind of stuff but it's about
privacy you can't just pick and choose
when you're for privacy so if you're for
privacy hi there don't click those
things yeah they shouldn't post them in
the first place but don't click them
because then you're just giving them
more incentive to one day take your
privacy away and one day when your
personal stuff is out there no matter
how benign it is you're going to really
have no right to to say that it
shouldn't be out there that people
shouldn't look at it
let for whatever little privacy we have
left just let it remain private please
people